all right one last question go ahead man
yeah yeah yeah got from Oklahoma why you
wearing Jordan's a Wrangler shirt and a
chucker hat because this is what I put
on today dumb [__] I put on Jordan a
trucker hat and a Wrangler shirt yeah
there you go can I ask you where you
bought that shirt a [__] oh my god
dude you're asking me what I'm wearing
holy [__] did you is that the last shirt
they sold at structure look at that
[__] thing dude the [__] out of here
you've been mad since you said something
dumb at the beginning of the show and I
responded to you you've been waiting to
say something funny that's what you came
up with [__] try
again so bad so you've been waiting all
day to say something you thought was
going to get me okay yeah there we go
thank
you I'm so sad to see that
happen I know you are brother I know I
am man listen it always makes me laugh
that get some boots that people talk up
I talk back and and they get their
feelings hurt and leave it is such a
[__] mystery to me you got his
feelings hurt and [__] left no dude
yeah I get it you wanted to ask a funny
question and it wasn't funny and then
you got embarrassed and now you got to
you're like I got to get out of here
this dude [__] sucks yeah dude yeah
dude yeah go I'll see
you see you in
Oklahoma it is fascinating to me man
that grown people this is my job right
and I do things and if you're going to
talk to me you've seen enough comedy
shows the comics going to talk back
right and the fact that one I think we
all knew just dressed how he was he was
not going to be
funny that was not something that that
dude was going to be good at I bet you
he could fry a pickle but I
don't I don't think he was going to be
fun but then the fact that nobody
laughed and I say something back dude a
grown man a grown [__] man got his
feeling feelings hurt and left I I'm so
glad I'm recording that I can't wait to
post
it Oklahoma Oklahoma Oklahoma all right
all
right here we go I'll look for it on the
Tik
Tok [__] I love the way you said that
dude your enunciation was [__] SP on
too we hit both KS real hard dick
D love you so much thank you I love you
I appreciate you guys being here all
right we're going to do two more songs
everybody did it get just get really
[__] hot in
here holy [__] nuts yeah everybody
uh what's that you're on fire I'm on
fire thanks
dude yeah [__] that guy like these
people